hey Jake can I show you something over
here sure thing web trying to send
Genevieve his sexy pic just move my
bubble but pop nope I'm out
excuse me pal squad meet detective
Adrian pimento
he's been deep undercover for the last
12 years but he's just resurfaced and
he's rejoining the nine-nine that yes
some of you just met detective pimento
and of course some of you knew him
before he went undercover Hitchcock and
Scully you guys still work here the only
way they're getting rid of us is in a
body bag it actually happened once but
it was a false alarm detective pimento
will be returning to his old desk
Peralta will temporarily be moved to the
break room questions what you do
undercover I work for Jimmy the butcher
Figgis that is an a-list mobster tell me
literally everything everyone shut up
pretty much just a bagman for him I mean
I did some other stuff we usually try to
tell funnier little stories well there's
nothing funny about what I did for the
butcher I've had to learn not to blink
because every time I close my eyes I see
a fresh horror Oh dark how do you keep
your eyes moist no actually I have a
very funny story about keeping my eyes
moist hey this is my desk okay okay well
now that that's out of the way I was
just coming to let you know we're gonna
work a B&E together we're gonna be
partners nope I work alone plus the
butcher says he has spies in the NYPD so
I trust none of these dildos listen you
can trust me I'm like obsessed with you
fine tell me something you've never told
another living soul ooh here's one I'm
actually not strong enough to lift a
water-cooler jug so I always find a way
to make Terry do it here's mine Jimmy
the butcher made me drive a croquet
wicket through a guy's eyes into his
brain
brain leaked out his eyes like he was
crying his own mind my goodness
now that I've heard yours I feel like my
watercolor thing could hold more juicy
but no that was embarrassing for you a
bond has been made
feels good to trust again brother Wow
either you are a cyborg or you're
carrying so many weapons in this jacket
hey kitchen now okay what's that man
something's not right about that guy why
just because it keeps threatening to
kill me in the middle of a police
precinct grow up because I'm physically
attracted to him damn that's bad I'm
only attracted creeps the vulture the
ShamWow guy when I was a kid had a major
crush on the evil gremlin stripe are you
crazy yeah well I'm not gonna bone gizmo
what careful with you Mentos it's gonna
be fine oh hey can I borrow that
Genevieve's out of town I need two
phones so I can send her a front date
and the baggage I don't want your ass in
my cloud Adrian are you living in the
break room no why do you ask
ah because you're shaving your shoulder
in our communal eating space you have a
bed set up on the couch stuff like that
fine busted my landlord kicked me out
because my stupid neighbors couldn't
handle a few tiny Knight screams I was
dreaming that someone was trying to
scalp me with a sharpened grapefruit
spoon
my brains fascinating I mean where does
it come up with this stuff when I was
undercover someone did try and scalp me
with a sharpened grapefruit spoon sure
that would do it aren't you dating Rosa
can't you just stay with her oh yeah no
we're doing this really hot thing where
we haven't told each other where we live
makes our sex play really erotic bar I
totally get that well you let me know if
there's anything I can do
oh yes I will stay at your home thank
you eat what no no you just said you
wanted to help unless you weren't being
serious which I would get I've been
betrayed before for instance by the
grapefruit spoon guy no no no no
definitely you could stay with me
ah you're the best Chuck thank you huh
but for real get yourself some good
earplugs because I really Don played how
horrible those nights creams are hot all
right I'll see you later Grammy
dears cement Oh what's up what's up with
you I need you to sign this report okay
I'll sign your report
what the hell
careful being still wet maybe this'll
help okay they got to knock that off
loosen up start somewhere love baby
it's March man shut up you punching
holes yeah that's way too much paper not
for me
can't even get a cup of coffee
well I'm off to find some yellow paper
so I can do this all over again
all right yes that's it what's going on
with you two
oh you noticed it yeah I noticed it
everyone's noticed it a convicted
pervert asked me if you guys could cool
it I don't know what to tell you
some between us Sarge something dark and
urgent hmm I could have done that yeah I
know you could have but you didn't I did
I mean there are lots of other polls
guys a whole street full of them so
Adrian I'm gonna stop messing around and
do this thing never what you know what I
just realized
I forgot something at home I'm just
gonna my claws honey Shh it's okay I'm
here
monsters aren't real my little pierogi
but I saw it was big and hairy you just
had a nightmare buddy no it was real
sure it felt that way but I I'm gonna
open this closet
and I'm gonna show you that there's
nothing in there don't do that blah blah
see hey Chuck its pimento and now
Nicholas says he's too frightened to
ever sleep again so that's just super
duper I don't understand what he's so
scared about if I was there to kill him
he never would have heard me I think you
told him several times god Nikolai's
just having such a rich childhood can we
back up what were you doing in Boyles
closet in the first place
well I still had a key from when I was
crashing there last year and I wanted to
shower and anoint my body with essential
oils before I saw Rosa duh well she's
gonna be so psyched that you're back
where have you been all this time Vegas
has been locked up for a month I was in
prison in Uzbekistan it's actually not
as bad as it sounds
why were you in jail uh I got shot down
smuggling ammo to a rebel group find an
old Soviet prop plane they tortured us
made me eat my co-pilots tongue move now
I've got a taste for it the important
thing is you're safe and sound and back
in Brooklyn Thank You captain
oh you smell good
wowza and end of ugh okay what happened
did she take the bait like a stupid fish
yeah she invited us to go out with our
gang tonight speaking of which captain
any luck getting coke out of evidence
one bag of primo blow as is the pro
loans I still have reservations about
this plan perhaps you could say your
dealer ran out or he's summering in
Nantucket
now this is perfect if she gets wasted
maybe she'll get sloppy and start
talking plus I mean I can teach you guys
how to fake take real drugs like a pro I
used to do it all the time when I was
undercover all you gotta do is close
your nostril when you go down watch this
oh nope I didn't do it that time I got a
full snout full whoa okay no let me just
try to get him a little rusty all you
got to do just close the old Noster
brownie in it oh boy yeah I got more
that time did you get this Adrian that's
enough oh we can make fake cocaine for
ourselves out of vitamin B powder ooh
vitamin B the second best vitamin guys
I'm telling you the fake Storting can
work what so much that time Oh anybody
wanna listen to Jamiroquai right now
Cam's gonna move this away from your
nose holes well you two should get going
if Hawkins tells you anything text me
right away I'll stay here and watch
Adrian boo thank you yeah all right hey
yeah you guys play an instrument you
know I play a little bit of bouzouki
anybody else play an ancient string at
instrument no you guys wanna go to the
beach beautiful day just maybe like get
out there throw the disc around right
hey have you ever been to the Statue of
Liberty captain have you have you been
inside like under the skirt like what's
up there did they build a you know what
I'm saying
[Music]
you